Sam how you doing man why you so angry
dad
[__] [__] nothing works I hate
everything my Apple TV's not working
quick times out lurking I hate zoo but
your Mohawks working that didn't even
work I meant to shave the whole thing
and I just forgot that up there you did
not forget the top dude I hate working
from home I hate it so much
don't worry just like I don't know six
to eight more weeks of this and then
we're back
if we're lucky if we're lucky okay so
let's do this is what we got let's jump
right in people need okay we are as
photovoltaic up today but I found I want
to talk about something that I think is
more interesting but you want to talk
about some light-hearted stuff which is
what's the sway thing yeah what is this
way thing I saw you I saw a video of you
dancing we got the first time you'd seen
this dance pretty well no I'd seen it
Ryan Hoover had posted one of him
dancing and when he posted it looked
very real to me yours did that looks as
real I think is where you were in your
room but when I saw that I was like holy
[__] Ryan could dance and then I saw the
comments and everyone was like nice app
nice how do we get the beta of this app
and I was like oh [__] there's an app
that makes you dance wait so you have
this app I think it's pretty popular
it's called sway and what it does is you
record yourself for 10 or 20 seconds you
just stand there and you like walk
around and move and then it uses AI or I
don't know what it is but or not AI it's
called um oh is it oh yeah yeah and then
makes it look like you're dancing like
really good and I send it to my family
and some like 20 of them they thought I
was dancing it was hilarious yeah it's a
it looks pretty it looks pretty funny K
if they actually just made it a little
bit less good of dancing it would look
real people
believe it but it's like so good that
you're like no way no it's pretty
amazing and so when I downloaded it it
was number 50 in the App Store and like
as I was playing with it I thought it's
big climbing up the charts did you just
download it cuz you were browsing the
App Store you saw somebody do it
so I all I do I browse the App Store and
I like to see the fastest growing apps
yeah and I like to figure out what's
going on I do that with gaming all the
time so I have to figure out the games
that are growing fastest so yeah we're
just browsing you gotta and but it is
viral like when you see somebody post it
all like yeah you're like oh this is
great I can I can like I should do that
so it has this kind of like monkey-see
monkey-do virality that i like well you
remember that app that um you you would
take a picture of your face and it would
make you look older right then it'd turn
out that that was owned by a Russian
company and they were like doing funny
stuff with your pictures well I don't
know if they were actually doing
anything but people were definitely
sketched out by it they're like wait I
just gave my camera access to some
random Russian developer so did like 50
million other people like justice just
to make this like old filter or baby
filter yeah so download that app it's
called sway dance is it called swayed
it's called sway for sure SWA why it's a
cool little app it's good for little
pranks and actually you know that is a
light harder way to start because it's
just funny and people should just go to
your twitter and they'll find the video
of you doing it but but this is also
like part of this deep fakes like this
deep fakes problem and so if you don't
know what a deep fake is a deep fake is
basically people can now use technology
to make a video look real you can make
anything look so for example what they
do is they'll take Obama Obama's talking
yeah but I can just say any sentence I
could just be like hey hey my name is
Barack and I'm the worst president of
all time and it'll make it look like his
lips are moving to my sentence because
they basically feed in a bunch of
footage of Obama talking normally and it
basically the algorithm learns okay
here's how Obama's face moves when he
says certain things and then when I I
can input any audio and it'll make it
look like he's doing it now right
the technologies where it looks a little
off but it's not that far off like if I
showed it to my not all of it leave that
off right but it's just getting better
month over month so they just showed a
like a paper just came out with a new
one and it's literally just taking a
still photo so they took the Mona Lisa
and then they do the same thing
I can go say a sentence and it will make
the Mona Lisa say it in like the voice
can we can is that good it's so like
it's pretty crazy that they can just do
that off a still photo you don't even
need like hours and hours of raw footage
of the person in order to do this now so
I downloaded an app that does that with
the Mona Lisa which app is that do you
remember yeah it's amazing
I'll tell you what it's called it's
really neat and I think that everyone
should download this stuff I paid $5.00
for it it's called no I don't remember
the name of it I got no worries
but what do you think of this whole
defacing cuz it's a big problem like
your sister's a lawyer and I think she
was she was like a DA before right
nurses yeah well I mentioned the public
defender in the Bronx and and people
yeah now it's like if you can't trust
what you see right if we don't have
photos that could be Photoshop audio now
that can be like live bird I think is
the name of it where basically you just
you just ha you can't you you can train
you can train this system to where you
could just type anything and it will say
it in your voice or it'll say Anna
Donald Trump's voice so if you can't
believe what you see what you hear or
what's in video then how does that like
mess up the world like fake news is
gonna become a bigger problem yeah it's
gonna become a problem why are we
defaulting to that why are we worrying
about I mean yeah it's gonna be a
problem but also let's think about all
the amazing things like like act like
there's gonna be fake actors like my
dance like your dance video it's gonna
make movies amazing like like Brad Pitt
won't exist they'll be it will be it'll
be AJ Pitt and it will be some fake
person and I think that's awesome so
here's a future world you literally are
just looking at your computer and
instead
like today if you want to make a movie
or an animation you have to like be an
animator or a movie editor or an artist
to be able to draw you're just gonna be
able to say things and it's gonna be
able to create what you're what you're
saying so you're gonna be able to say
okay what if Donald Trump was talking to
you know whatever Barack Obama and then
Donald jumped in the air and he said
this and then literally it's just gonna
be able to animate that's how that's how
far this is gonna go and that's gonna
unlock the ability to create stuff to
people who don't have the technical
skills to do it today yeah I mean I'm
I'm not too worried about how they're
gonna regulate it because like if you
have a political ad now it like anyone
can run an ad on Facebook or on TV and
it says Donald Trump I'm Donald Trump
and I hate Mexicans anyone could do that
now but I mean like literally the tech
like you could buy ads but there are
ways to say like well no that's not
allowed and it has to say like I'm
Donald Trump and I support this you know
what I mean like there are ways to like
would even like if you run a TV a
political TV ad right now it has to say
who pays for it sure it has to say is
this but it doesn't have to be it
doesn't have to be a political thing
right this can go for anyone someone in
high school could just bully somebody
else like right now the thing that yeah
I think thanks deep fakes got famous
because people were putting other
people's faces on porn actors and you
could make it look like I could take a
photo of your mom and I could put it on
it put it into a porno and it would look
like your mom's in the porno and people
were doing this with celebrities people
were doing this with their classmates
and you know the reddit the subreddit
for this got huge is our slob fix our
slash deep fakes and so this is how we
got popular because it was like this
incredible bullying tool like forget
about political ads it's just like
slander left and right it did it did it
get taken down that subreddit no I think
it's still up and I haven't been in a
long time but when it first blew up you
know it got really popular because
people were you know if oh yeah it is
banned from reddit now because it was
like it was becoming a problem
oh yeah but that they didn't stop the
actual the actual problem it just
stopped the subreddit where people were
sharing it
so so I think there's going to be a
massive massive problem for evidence I
think it's a bit gonna become a massive
problem for just like slander and you
know spin like I could I could take a
video of you it'd make it say that you
hate Mexican people and it's not Trump
and and people would believe it because
they would see your face and they would
say I saw him say that yeah yeah I don't
know and so I'll tell you what some
people are trying to do to combat this
there's a whole bunch of programmers who
programmers in general I have a high bar
for the truth they really want things to
be true logical soluble rule up reliable
and so when you take away evidence
evidence which used to be a source of
truth it's like well you're saying this
but I have a video of you doing that
thing so that's evidence but now it's
like well this video could be anything
this video could be faked so they're
trying to solve the way that they think
it can be solved so the theory is
anything you make to sort of validate
stuff the con artists will always be one
step ahead and there's too big of a
payoff to be able to fake this stuff
well it's like a counterfeit er and so
you're always a cat-and-mouse game which
is not a winning solution so the
solution that they believe is that the
phone makers themselves the device
makers themselves will need to put a
cryptographic seal on the video when
it's taken and it's like a tamper-proof
seal like we have with medicine or
whatever where it's like if this seal is
broken that means this videos been
edited in some way and so at some point
people will only trust videos or photos
that have this this cryptographic seal
on them that says this has not been
edited because it's it's on the device
itself from when it got captured it gets
instantly implemented on and so it was
working on that well the problem is a
startup can't do this right because it's
actually Apple that needs to implement
it it's actually Samsung that needs to
implement this and so luckily apples are
pretty privacy conscious company and
they know that like if their tools are
being used for evil they'd usually
actually do stuff about it so hopefully
Apple is working on this but I have a
friend who was doing a start-up trying
to do this and he was running into this
problem which is like look the people
who need to do this are all all the
camera makers like you know the security
camera itself needs to do this and
that's the only like decent solution now
some technical people will say Oh
there's nothing that's actually
tamper-proof you can still you can still
you know get around but it's better and
there they are right but there are still
things where it's mostly it mostly works
right exactly so I think that's the
world that's the way the world is going
to work later where you're gonna need to
see this little you know icon that says
it's like you know it's the gluten-free
icon it's the organic organic icon it's
gonna be this is legitimate and there's
gonna be a legitimacy icon on any foot I
can't business that's a good business
you know JD Power no I mean I've heard
of it but I don't know what you're gonna
tell me right now but you know what it
is so right it's like all I know
eighty-five JD Power JD Power and
Associates that's all I know what does
that mean okay so JD Power the reason I
looked into this because I wanted to
create a business like this where I was
like because I was like this is a
[__] racket and I'm like it does
sound it does give a little it does give
value if there if you but you have to be
like a benevolent dictator where like
you can like rule it but you really
gotta be honest otherwise does a service
right right and JD power what they do is
it's a billion dollar company
JD Power is and I mean what they do is
they test different cars and they give
it a wards but the way that they make
money is the car companies are members
of the organization so if you're like if
you know if you only want the money you
don't give a [__] about like being
ethical you could be like hey Ford like
our new membership cost this much money
are you guys in or out and just so you
know if you're out we can't give you an
awards that's crazy yeah that yeah if
you could be in the business of being
the rating agency that is gold in fact
you know but one of the problems is like
if people remember during the subprime
crisis I believe what happened was these
subprime mortgages the bonds that were
the securitized housing bonds the
mortgage bonds were rated triple-a and
people were like well how was this rated
triple-a this is like a junk bond well I
wouldn't be ready to triple-a and I
think I believed this the companies I
think it was the banks that were funding
Standard & Poor right so if Standard &
Poor was the rating agency and they were
the one sort of funneling money exactly
the same thing it's the same thing and
so they lost their or they didn't
actually lose it they're still around
they're still one of the kind of main
reading agencies but like that's a
breach of breach of trust when the only
thing you're providing is trust as a
service yeah it's the same thing so JD
Power was sold to mcgraw-hill in 2005
for four hundred million dollars and
then it was sold again recently in 2000
in 819 I think for north of a billion
right I've really been wanting to do the
same thing I was like you haven't wanted
to create a credentialing agency so
either in the standardized testing world
so like you know the way SAT no these
these things are a racket because they
can charge whatever the hell they want
because you need that credential to move
forward and these credentials were you
know for the most part all these
credentials was created at one point in
time and so I was looking into like is
there another credential that I could
create that literally all I'm providing
is a stamp and I just get paid for for
further stamp well you know what I've
always wanted to do that similar is a
vendors list so like Sean if you're
launching something you're gonna come to
me because you think I know a little bit
about copywriting and you're gonna say
you know any copywriters I'm gonna be
like I know 102 but like they're hard to
find and so in my head I'm like I just
got to create Sam's list we're just have
like approved vendors and now this is
the best why are you saying this is the
best are you saying these are 10 that
you should check out or you think this
is the best one like wire cutter well I
don't think you could do the best one
because if you have the best copywriter
that person will always be busy but like
there are definitely like dozens or
hundreds that you can approve I mean I
guess Angie's List was something similar
and that's huge but like I've always
wanted to do this for copywriters in
particular I was I almost bought say I
almost did Sam's list because people
always like which copywriters should I
do I'm like I don't know ma'am look I
could post on my social media about like
it's a lot of work for me to go and find
them for you right but like the same
thing with law firms the same thing with
accountants right I'm like man I gotta
go straight like a vendors
of people who I'd know and approve of
that's cool the version of this I wanted
to do was around either IQ so I was like
oh okay like mints I like can I
basically create some [__] tests
that essentially labels people and
they're you know if you're in the top 5%
you get this extra little certificate
and so people would pay to basically
have that as as a bragging right or I
was also thinking about it for
developers like is there a just an extra
credential you could pay $39 to get that
basically says yes I know X language or
I am competent I have this level of
competency at this thing and I'm really
a big fan of if anyone's out there
creating a credential you know
credentialing agency or trust us the
service I'm very very interested in
those because I think those are
beautiful beautiful businesses extremely
easy to run low cost low risk and the
more you do it the more powerful they
become because the more your the more
times you see JD power even if you don't
even fully know what it is it's like we
need to go get that that's the that's
the standard so I just looked up men so
while you're talking they have a hundred
and fifty they're a non-profit it's a
hundred and fifty thousand members and
they do about four point eight million
dollars a year in sales interesting I'm
not that big I wonder the back story
yeah but like as a nonprofit you never
know like what's the what was their
motive how are they doing things well
but you do know dude you can go and look
at that all there they have to file a
[__] of government form and you can see
how much the how much they pay
themselves how much revenue and what
their expenses are right guys I guess
I'm saying as I haven't I haven't done
that part like the same thing can be
done for athletes by the way like you
know how NFL players go through the
combine which is basically this battery
of tests you run a 40-yard dash you do
this bench press 185 pounds you do a
vertical leap test and so I really
wanted I really think there's somebody
could create a credentialing thing where
you just have this facility in different
cities and people pay to come in to get
officially tested to get their scores
it's like here's how good I am as an
athlete and then they use that when
they're trying to basically like get on
a you teams or get college scholarships
or whatever it is it's like today we
only offer that to NFL players right
before they get drafted but I think that
this should be a sort of a standard
service for athletes to say hey what's
my reaction time what's my annuity test
was my verticals I did that
when I was a kid when I was in high
school I did the same thing he was
called spark and okay s PE a R Q and the
guy who created it was a X he was a
college a very elite college runner in
the 70s and 80s I think his name was
Rudy Rudy Chapa I'm remembering this off
the top of my head Rudy Chapa he was a
2-mile ER from California in high school
he I think he had the high school state
rec or high school national record for
the two-mile at like 8:30 something
right and his name is Rudy Chapa I think
am i right
is his name Rudy Chapa I'm on the
website right yeah I don't even look at
his name but yeah this looks interesting
and before me for this test and he was a
Nike executive and then he created the
spark test and what you did it was very
similar to a combine and it was and I
did it I crushed it it was a 40-yard
40-yard dash a broad jump a vertical
jump how far you can throw a medicine
ball right and maybe that's it and they
would give you a score and that score
and I went to this place called velocity
sports in velocity sports was created by
the coach of Ellis huge track and field
and it was a chain of gyms that you can
go to for high school kids and running
straight like that and the velocity
sports must have paid spark money to use
it and then when you applied to college
I would put my spark score to get a
scholarship
yes dude that's exactly what I'm
thinking about and I'm looking at their
website now looks very basic but this is
interesting I think there's a lot of
unused facilities like track track and
field that are underused so much of the
time that you could do this without
capex probably as long as you say like
you know when you run a race and it's
like as long as the wind conditions are
under this then it's in effect this
counts and the official thing right so I
bet you could use you know in the summer
time schools that are empty you could
use their track and field facilities and
build and build a program like this
because now people with sports are
parents with sports or that become so
crazy where people are doing travel
sports at like age six eighty seven
you're paying thousands of dollars for
your seven-year-old to play baseball
beyond this like elite team and this is
like a multi-billion dollar industry of
the travel sports industry and I think
all those people would be people who
would want to get their kid tested and
you could drive Facebook Ads to say hey
get your kid tested
here's your school what's your score and
then every year you want it upgraded
because it's like oh I've gotten
stronger and faster and taller so I want
my official measurements that are that
are sort of ratified and here's another
example of this is this is kind of funny
we're kind of ranking on this I didn't
do research on this other than like I
didn't prepare for this so I mean either
I just thought of this idea of while we
were talking that's how [__] great
we are dude just take a minute to
appreciate that you know um Gallup I do
know Gallup yes okay so yeah
did my microphone are we it's a good
okay so Gallup is is a polling polling
company created by this guy named Joseph
Gallup I think and the another company
like a smaller company bought Gallup and
it was a family-owned business and the
founder of that company that bought
Gallup his name was I forget his name
exactly but do you remember strengths
finder yes the guy who owned the family
business that bought Gallup he is the
author of strengths finder I see and so
strengths
tranqs finder it's hard for me to say
they have a book that is popular little
bit it's even though it's popular it
doesn't make nearly the amount of money
that the company makes the company makes
about a billion or two billion dollars a
year it's privately owned it's probably
one of the largest privately owned
companies in America like top 200 and
they have a quiz so if you google
strengths finders quit is it's a $29 or
$49 quiz and it tells you where you rank
on strengths finder right I've taken it
because somebody sent it to me Jim
Clifton is the name of the guy Jim
Clifton Jim Clifton his dad Jim Clifton
was the CEO of Gallup right and this was
his thing and so it was like a survey
they make hundreds of millions of
dollars a year off that quiz yes exactly
so I've taken transponders and I this is
when I was like oh this is just [__]
okay gotcha
like first of all it's a 10
you can't fail it's just saying which of
these strengths do you have so you're
just gonna get one of the 25 strengths
or whatever it's like here's the 5 UK
leadership determination and you know
innovation and whatever and then the
other person gets like empathy and you
know thoughtfulness and whatever else so
it's pretty genius and they sell these
to companies who wanna basically take
these personality tests for leaders to
say hey we want to understand our
employees better you want to understand
your team teammates better and this will
help you work together better and I
believe strength finders was doing like
a hundred million plus in revenue I have
to go do double check that but but yeah
it's like a tremendously successful
franchise and the book is really just a
it's like a code you get in the book
that says go take these queries online
and then the book is like kind of
useless beyond that but you can yes it
works really well using that book
because like I said I've kind of talked
about this me and Ramon we own this
check this this this software for to us
and we get all of our signups
practically because one guy who has a
book mentioned our service and it gets
signups in the books not even popular
that's amazing
also like we you talked about that
person in our Facebook group that my
first million side hustles Facebook
group basically who is doing a chess
tutoring service any niche sport or
niche niche thing like chess I don't
know if it probably is already fits just
is still widely established but probably
is already some sort of benchmark or
test you take but if I was him I would
really create my own anyways which is
like oh by the way for all my students
like once a year we do this hundred
dollar you know test and you get your
chest chest q score and what your chest
Q score tells you your adaptability your
you know recognition cognition whatever
and and as well it's not like total
horseshit you actually are testing to
see how good they are at certain things
but I think it's a it's just a very
simple way to make a lot of money off of
kind of paper where there's nothing
physical you're doing there paper where
in that it's real but it's it's
lightweight it's very simple to create
it's very simple to maintain
no like employees or assets you need to
buy well because it's not someone in the
reviews our latest review says that you
and I are unethical and that you have to
check your ethics at the door if you got
to listen to this podcast it's totally
[__] but I just want to make them
aware that would you say vaporware you
be it's real or its substance but yeah
vaporware is the wrong word for what I
meant is a very lightweight thing to
create and maintain and very low cost to
create another example of this is Doug
score do you know Doug score never heard
of it dude it's just this guy named Doug
tomorrow he's this nerd like he's like
the nerdiest guy ever and he's got like
4 million subscribers on YouTube and
like he's the type of guy who wears like
a collared shirt but like you can see
his white undershirt sticking out from
like the sleeves you know he's like just
like a sloppy dirty guy but he's amazing
he has a thing where he reviews cars and
he creates a Doug score which is based
off of like is this fun for a weekend
car or is this fun for a daily driver
and now at this point he's got a
thousand cars that he's ranked and I'm
when I'm buying my car now I check it I
checked the Doug score
I like that okay that's cool like Kelley
Blue Book prefer value and then Doug
score for sort of enjoyment I like that
and Kelley Kelley Blue Book
great example so looks a multi-billion
dollar company
yeah but they provide a little different
thing they have just like a data set
that they're able to use to give you a
price comparison which is like different
than sort of an aptitude test but
nonetheless I'm curious do you think we
are low ethics do you think you have a
sort of a looser ethical criteria than
most people for business I think that we
have a looser attitude yes but by the
way I think it's it's significantly
above the line of like good like right
like for example most people are like I
can't pre saw product that I don't have
and I'm like in my head I'm like who
cares just refund to people and like you
haven't you something I'm not saying
steal money I'm saying advertise
something it doesn't exist you can get
demand improved a man and then
you refund the money I'm not saying you
steal from them but yeah you are lying
and so I think that's ethical right yeah
I think we definitely have a looser
definition than the average person I
would say the average maybe the average
business person even but there is you
know I think the problem here is there's
no standard right there's no there's no
definition for what's ethical what's not
it's completely subjective and
judgmental and so the hard part is you
know for us we think there's a line
between right and wrong and we're on the
right side we we think we have a safe
margin of a buffer where we're in the
right but for other people their line
might be in a different spot yeah but
that's because most people aren't
aggressive but anything that I do
I would I would suggest to my mom that
she buy whatever I'm promoting or like
it's like do I want my family to use
this or or if I told them about what I'm
doing what I like do I want to hide this
right and I don't I'm I'm anything that
I could do I'm not afraid to tell I met
this guy once this guy had reached out
to me about we're building this product
called blab and blab was getting popular
this guy reached out he said hey my name
is Billy I'm from you know from like
Santiago or the term X or somewhere and
let him and he was like I'm coming up to
California I'm coming to San Francisco I
want to meet you and I want to talk to
you about this company I was like okay I
don't know about that like most of
people who that are users of a product
or not usually people I want to like do
meetings with necessarily but he said a
bunch of stuff in his email that made
him sound amazingly legit he was like my
family started the first television
station in Mexico we you know I own all
these different like music festivals and
he said he sounded like super legit but
his emails written with blue text font
and like different sizes of texts yeah
no no not like that like it was like
IKEA Cho's like no I'm gonna my emails
are blue and not the like copy-paste a
little purple thing it was like this was
just a style so I was like I don't know
this guy's a joker enough anyways we go
out to dinner and I have very low hopes
we go to a sushi place and I walk in and
I see probably the most handsome guy
I've ever seen and this guy Billy was
only well-put-together he's like in a
suit and tie he looks legit he we sit
down on the table he orders the omakase
which is basically chef's choice like
$200 each sushi dinner and he's like I
got this don't worry and I'm like okay
I'm starting to believe it but you know
could be could still be someone who's
faking it and he starts telling me a
story and this guy is completely legit
he's probably the most charismatic guy
I've ever met my whole life I was like
you know if if I swung that way I'd be
in love right now like this guy is
amazing so at the end of the dinner I
asked him a question I said hey you know
you're a very persuasive guy like this
was you clearly are good at this right
you're clearly very persuasive very
charming I said I used to think I'm that
way till I met you basically I used to
think I was in the sort of top tier of
that but I all sort of had this
hesitation of like you know should I use
my powers for good or evil type of thing
like where do you draw the line on using
this but this guy's look dead he was a
real completely legit and so he really
was wealthy very successful very smart
very charming all that good stuff and so
I asked him I said you know what do you
think he goes my rule is this because if
your intentions are good then it's all
fair game and so he was like he was like
it all the matters of the intent if
you're trying to scam people if you're
trying to con people if you're trying to
not deliver value if you're trying to
just get something that's a good
situation for you and not for the other
person then you shouldn't be doing it
what you shouldn't be using all these
powers of persuasion sake but if you
think you are genuinely gonna help
people if you think you are genuinely in
the right if you think you're generally
working for a good cause if your mission
is pure if your intent is good then it's
all fair game you should use it to the
max and I was like aren't Billy thank
you very much for this incredible I
completely agree with him and if you
study you know like persuasion and charm
and I use it in the form of copywriting
that's all some people are born better
but it's a teachable skill and I always
tell people like what I'm gonna tell you
it's gonna sound like evil like I'm
gonna teach you how to manipulate people
but make sure you use it for good
right because you can easily use this
for bad and you know what here's a
here's a weird counter to this this is
where you know people are gonna be like
okay this guy's actually evil okay so
the other way of doing this so that's
one way one other thing is to say what
you just said which is
use these powers for good the other
thing I've been able to do is the
opposite which is when I see somebody do
something for evil but it works
I try to learn from it and so for
example remember the first time I saw
I'll give you a recent example first no
I completely agree
so Trump is somebody who I'm not a fan
of I think the guy is bad in all these
different ways but when I watch him the
guy is an incredibly effective
communicator and he's not polished he
doesn't use fancy $15 words he doesn't
have a lot of substance behind what he's
saying but the guy is like a master of
of communication the guy knows how to
get his point across in a way that
resonates with people I completely agree
Scott Adams who's the creator of Dilbert
was talking about this when Trump was
running if you haven't seen it go read
Scott Adams his blog he's the creator of
Dilbert and he was early on when Trump
first announced his candidacy Scott
Adams called it he goes this guy's gonna
win and people were like what he goes
I've been studying persuasion for twenty
years I've been studying hypnosis I've
been a communicator through cartoon I
know an effective communicator when I
see one
this guy is a master he goes and he said
he would come up whenever Trump would
say things like low-energy Jeb or
whatever and he would like called Jeb
Bush Low Energy
he was like these are linguistic kill
shots these are when he would talk about
the wall he bug it's a great big wall a
huge wall and he's like he's painting a
picture in people's minds which is much
better than talking about policy and so
you can learn from people that you think
are using it for money he and he called
not that he was gonna win he called he
was gonna win months before anybody even
took him seriously when 538 was like
this guy's got a 0% chance
Scott Adams was like this guy's gonna
win and of course if he was wrong nobody
would ever even really pay attention to
it because you know but when you're
right on a contrarian prediction you get
all the credit and the other example of
this was Hitler so Hitler when Hitler
was rising to power I studied how did
this guy get so popular what did this
guy do because when you watch him speak
he's not a very compelling guy but they
did a lot of things so one thing I
remember that stood out to me because I
was in seventh grade and I'm never
learning about this
when Hitler was trying to rise to power
all the political campaign posters were
all like full-color lots of text people
trying to explain their position on
things and Hitler with the other way
everything he did was black and white
which would be normally it would not
stand out but he was like well I will
contrast everybody else who's do using
tons of color on their stuff I'll go
black and white the second thing was he
would use only like big images and like
really powerful images and not a bunch
of text and then he would use movies as
propaganda and you know fill the cinema
with people to watch a movie but it was
very much a propaganda thing behind it
so even though he used it for evil those
techniques and principles are
interesting to learn from for me as
somebody who wants to you know have a
strong toolkit that I can use for good
I completely agree I was reading I've
been going on so many Wikipedia holes
now that I'm home so much I wasn't
reading about I read Hitler's Wikipedia
I was reading about World War two and it
let me like I was worried about the
Mafia and then world war two and they're
like it's like he's there like his rise
to power was because he like would speak
at these I don't know what what the
equivalent of is now but just like halls
where he drank like bars like veteran
halls and I'm like wait a minute he
started as a speaker that's it right it
was kind of crazy so a couple of things
we'll switch topics cuz people now are
like what these guys are saying Trump
and Hillary are good and I don't
understand okay so I have an idea for
you so I call this my new lambda school
idea have you ever do you guys have like
an office administrator or office admin
I don't know if you guys are we have
yeah I mean we have someone who handles
stuff yes I do
sar and things like that right I'm
talking more like so I had been work or
like an executive assistant or secretary
do you have anybody like that have you
ever so recently I'm at my work we're
hiring an EI right so we had any a she
left we had to hire a new executive
assistant and so they put me on the
hiring panel and I'm like okay I don't
know what questions I'm supposed to ask
like I don't really know what the
background I should be looking for all
that stuff
so I started thinking about this store
looking it up so it turns out that
office administrators or secretaries or
executive administrators EA's it's one
of the most popular jobs in the country
and it's also something where so there's
about you know I'd say 600,000 I think
in the US and they pay pretty well so it
doesn't require tons of specialized
skill that's pretty much anybody can
learn to do this if you're you know
somewhat competent but you can make 50
60 70 80 K doing this I thought that's a
pretty good paying job and I know at our
company the EAA is they're critical they
do such an amazing job they they're they
help and all the senior leaders do what
they do and so I started looking about
this and I said could there be a lambda
school for EA's because I think this is
something that in three months you could
teach people the core skills that you
need around calendaring booking travel
you know note taking all the different
sort of core components that you need to
do to do this job well you know it's not
rocket science you just need to learn
the tools and learn the sort of do's and
don'ts and then I think companies when
you know like us when we're hiring for
this there's no like school or degree
that you look at or you like oh because
you have this degree you're gonna do a
good job and so it's usually like do you
already have experience doing this or
not but that's a catch-22 because how do
you break in if everyone wants to hire
for somebody who already has experience
doing it and so I'm thinking that you
could create a program that tells it
offers people who says hey in three
months we can train you for a job
that'll pay you 50 60 or 70 K here and
it's a job that has good you know
work-life balance and all this other
characteristics of it and so and you
could use the lambda school model where
you take an income share agreement you
say great I'm training people for three
months it cost me three thousand dollars
to do this remote virtual school but I
make back you know up to fifteen K 17 K
per candidate that gets placed into a
job over time what do you think of this
idea [__] love it and I'm looking it
up right now
org org dot Co have you heard of or gorg
no we use it let's see how big their
team is that can kind of tell us how big
they are but okay what or org is is it's
a community / to me
unity slash job board it's not the cup I
don't know how you would describe it in
one word it's a or gorg is a 100%
volunteer run organization we have job
or blogs resources we have private
groups an email lists and it's all for
HR right executive assistants office
manager HR departments and DIY admin
assistant like you know whatever its and
so my our old ei was on this and it was
an email list and and they would send
out blasts like hey I'm looking for the
best
IIT person our company small we only
have a budget of $2,000 who do you
recommend or like when I wanted to hire
new ei I had a friend post a listing on
there and I got tons of applicants what
I would do with your idea is I would
either buy this company
man these these the lady who runs this I
forget her name but she could be making
millions off of this but I don't think
she is I bet she's making hundreds of
thousands of dollars so like I would buy
that yeah I would buy that ID or become
the platinum sponsor for you know fairly
fair rate and use it for the sort of the
user acquisition and there's this
powerful thing because once you build
the brand that hey yeah this is it's
like a staffing agency right but it's a
it's a big internet internet version of
a staffing agency and once you place
some people to good things happen the
first is you get a reputation that says
hey RTA's I've been hired by company a
ABCDE and if we could come become a
trustworthy source for good EA's but
then also right now all the candidates
in our current be a pipeline came from
our existing EA's people they knew from
their network and so is your alumni
become your hiring become your hiring
partners and so the more alumni you
place the more opportunities you have
for your own graduates and so I think
that's like the real power of the lambda
school model and unlike okay so the
ladies girl model you gotta break that
[__] down lambda school model you're
saying and you train them for free and
then you get a percentage of their
salary yes I love that model for
everything not for everything
necessarily but I think when you have a
low cost of training it's a great model
because it reduce
is the friction to join because they say
well it's free and so I only I only have
to pay them if I get a high-paying job
out of this so your incentives are
aligned right because we want you to get
a high paying job and you came to us to
get a high paying job we only get paid
if you get a high paying job and if you
get a high paying job this is a
reasonable payback for for us providing
that service to you and so I think
anyway any place where you have a low
cost of training this is a very good
mechanism it's not just a dent mechanism
it gets a lot of hype but really it's
just a debt vehicle and but I think it's
a good debt vehicle for this okay do you
wanna I have a few things that I want to
go over do you want to wait until next
episode or you want to let's do one more
and then we'll call it and then we'll
save the rest for the night okay then I
don't want to bring let's not bring mine
up yet
the reason why what I wanted to talk
about was Roger Dickies bathroom
business that you brought up yeah made
your maid renovation I think but I kind
of want to wait you want to wait okay we
can do it next time okay let's bring up
let's let's Oh
why don't you bring up this save your
kneel story okay yes all right so Xavier
Neil I'm sorry I feel like I've been
talking most okay it's really
interesting
so Xavier Neil is my new favorite
billionaire so this is my second section
this is my segment of the show called my
new favorite rich guy
so this guy is essentially like a Elon
Musk type of dude in France but instead
of trying to send rockets to Mars
this guy just operates in his own style
but he's got the same kind of call like
no [__] given attitude like a Branson
or an Elon Musk and I never heard of
this guy so I'll tell you how I
discovered him so I discovered him
because he created this thing called 42
have you ever heard of the school called
42 No so it makes me in France he's in
France he so I'll tell you his kind of
like life story so age 19 he creates
this business called minute L minute L
is essentially a sex hotline a phone
service you call it so colleagues on a
sex line and at 19 he creates this thing
and it goes gangbusters and so he's
doing really well makes a few million
bucks off this then he either creates or
invest and bye-bye
stake in something called world net sold
a few years later for 50 million bucks
right before the dot-com crash and then
his big thing that he did was he created
this thing called free and free was like
a t-mobile it's like a mobile carrier
and at the time in France all like SMS
phone plans are all very expensive so he
created that he undercut everybody he
created a like lowest cost way to have
you know a cellular cellular service and
so 3d became this huge company so his
net worth ballooned to like six point
six billion dollars I'm looking him up
now this guy is my favorite person ever
yeah he's he's very legit and so he was
like alright look what do I want to do
now I want to do more baller [__] and so
he was like okay I'm gonna create this
thing called 42 so he was like I'm gonna
create a computer science school with no
teachers and no staff so all he did was
create this dope facility with a bunch
of computers and if you get into 42 you
just come and the computer is your
lesson plan so it's like a video game
there's like a challenge it's like hey
you need to make a website that could do
XY and Z you're like okay and it's like
you have the internet and you have some
people next to you and like you guys
need to figure out how to get past this
level and so you start doing the program
and so it's self-serve you do it you do
a bunch of like projects to level up
plus you create your own you know like
projects or ideas so somebody created I
don't know like somebody could create
like a coronavirus tracker right now
because that's a timely little website
you can yeah I'm looking it up now they
have 2,500 students yeah and it's
actually closed right now because the
physical facility it closed here but it
was a wild idea I don't even know how
successful it's been I don't think it's
been a wild success but I love his bet
so he was like yeah I'm gonna put a
hundred fifty million dollars into this
so he built one in France and he built
one here in Fremont for a hundred
million dollars in California and it was
just like so what a rep what a radical
idea what a way to bet your money and
try to like change the world over and
over and over again and then he did this
thing in in France he's like okay how do
I build like startup ecosystem here so
he created this thing called station F
and if you just think it's like the
[__] NASA facility it's like this
huge huge bike like I don't know how
many football fields long office or
hanger or co-working space and he's like
alright I'm gonna make the dopest place
for any investor to come when they're in
Europe here here's some space to go hang
out
entrepreneurs you're starting companies
come over here and build your company
here's an office space restaurants come
here at the bottom fill this place up
you know gym whatever so he created his
own little oasis how like Tony Shea did
in Vegas this guy did in France
this guy's a mainstay Chanel what what I
just love this guy's style so first of
all I've looked it up out he's not
perfect 2004 he was indicted and
detained for a month for misuse of
company assets which occurred in several
of his sex shops that he was a
shareholder in and he ended up getting a
two-year suspended prison sentence for
misuse of company assets so he's
certainly not perfect I don't know I'm
just reading up this one thing though in
addition to all this t owns the rights
of the song my way by Frank Sinatra
which I love the only one of the largest
newspapers in France super interesting
guy when I'm curious about people like
this and Andrew Wilkinson is gonna be on
the pot is he gonna be on on this
Tuesday yeah next the next episode
basically so Andrew kind of did Andrew
not exactly but kind of does a soy in
the same way as well until we have to
ask him about this what I want to know
is how do these people manage so many
freakin projects like cuz like I I can't
even manage what I have on my plate and
like right so it's nice never live it so
they you know they hire hire people to
run their [__] right so like I worked
with a guy Michael birch who's kind of
like this like billionaire type of dude
and he created this incubator with his
totally different model or everybody
owns all the equity in all the projects
and you know he picked me to run this
run the show for him so he truck any
trusted me he's pretty hands-off we
checked in but like he let me run the
show so I was looking at this guy Xavier
Neil and he's got somebody this woman
from Google who runs station after being
the big facility he's got somebody who
runs his investment fund and the guy
that guy was telling the story goes you
know we don't have board meetings but I
was like Xavier don't you want to know
what I'm doing with your fund and say
hey you know tell me and he's like the
he goes I told him I said hey we invest
in all these companies I think we should
double down on these winners and make
make less small investments and and do
more on the winning companies so what do
you say okay he goes he goes I'm not
turned I'm not doing this to make
money I'm doing this to make more
companies invest in more companies and
because I was like what he's like he's
like you could double down but don't
stop investing in new and like new small
small companies and then the other thing
that they talked about in his thing kind
of like what you're saying how do you
manage this they're showing like the guy
showed his email inbox all the emails
from this guy and I've noticed this a
lot of wealthy busy people their emails
look like text messages so like this guy
won't ride him a long email about like
hey we're thinking about this plan
here's what we could do here Plaza hey
okay cool or like literally it's up to
you all good it's like up but number two
the letter U okay where do I see this
screenshot there was a story I think was
like a Forbes or Bloomberg story or
something about this guy in there but I
think there's a pretty common thing
amongst the people who do a lot of I
guess like if I buy like like I'm
talking about how I'm gonna buy just a
toy car like a fun car I guess I'd be
like the equivalent of meat buy me like
a ten thousand dollar car I'm like
letting someone use it and it's like do
you not care just make sure it comes
back in one piece so you know the thing
I guess the thing I want to clarify
because when Andrews coming on on
Tuesday I'm I like Andrew for the same
reason I like this guy and they're
totally different right Andrews not gone
to jail and didn't start a sex hotline
and it's not a billionaire like well we
don't know that for sure
this guy has about 20 years on but I
guess like the thing the thing that
stands out to me is I respect above all
else people who do [__] their own way
people who have their own they are
original thinkers and decide to live
life on their own terms that's kind of
what I got out of this guy is I think I
feel like this guy Branson Elon Musk the
thing I like about them and they're
definitely have lots of flaws and lots
of you know messed up things that they
do but I just respect that they don't
just follow a normal societal playbook
they live life on their own terms they
basically you know Marshalls beat of
their own drum or whatever that's what I
like about them that's what I like about
Andrew he's done it completely his way
which is very non-traditional do you
think this guy speaks good English
this French guy yeah let's uh he's
alright let's [__] email yeah let's
do it
I'm looking at them now I I mean I would
if you're French I mean if you're a
magnet like this I would imagine you you
speak some English but is he good enough
English to be on this I'm sure yes I'm
sure we'll learn French dude we will
make it happen if we need to yeah it'll
be like yo yo el Romero and Joe Rogan we
just has a translator on the podcast I'm
down I would love to do this and this
guy's in cahoots with this other guy who
I don't want to say his name because
it's too embarrassing if I pronounced if
I try to sit snake it say it because
he's French but I its Bernard
I'll Arnold do you know who that is they
don't they'll be engaged okay I'll tell
you really quick
he's usually goes back and forth with
gates and a few these other guys as the
richest guy in the world
he LLVM H it stands for Louie Vuitton
something but they own Chanel they only
Vuitton they own
it's the largest luxury group in the
world they own fen phen what's the
Rihanna yeah yeah they own that so the
way he started it was his father was
wealthy and they owned a construction
business and it was big but it wasn't
like billionaire big but I think they
sold it for like 20 million dollars in
in the 60s which is a lot of money I
mean that's probably the equivalent of
20 million that's probably the
equivalent of a hundred million now so
it's a lot of money and so anyway he
convinced his father when this guy
Bernard was in his 20s and he goes dad
we got a diver we got to sell our
construction business and buy luxury
goods cuz when I went to New York they
all knew what Chanel was but that's not
even a big company and so he goes
[__] by Chanel and so they bought
Chanel for a small sum millions of
dollars but not what it's worth now and
then he runs it and he could start
buying more and more and more so he
turned a construction company into the
owner of Louie Vuitton and dude they
owned a lot of [__] so I'm just throw
off some names so they are on Belvedere
they own Hennessy they are D or they
aren't Effendi they own Fenty they own
tag they own who bloke they on my way
they own I mean this is
like a like I don't know a luxury brand
that's not on this list
yeah they own it all like do they but
then like Gucci I think Gucci's its own
brand yeah it's kind of like you know
like they a be in Banff where it's like
you two companies own like all the other
sub companies
yeah well this freaking guy did it and
he it started as a construction business
right and this doesn't happen that much
anymore but this is what I love about
business before for some reason it seems
like this happened this hat you this
used to happen a lot more the Chinese
are notorious for doing this where they
diversify like crazy so I don't think
this doesn't happen more I think this is
just something that happens on like a 50
year horizon and so it's just hard for
us who's like we're just for five years
we've just been furiously looking this
or 10 years to see these things that are
playing out over 50 or 100 year arcs
right I agree I agree with you but I've
studied a handful of Chinese companies
that were launched in the 90s and 2000's
and they are like crate easy about doing
that right where like they would start
something in like two years later they
own like apartment buildings it's like
what the heck that's not even like and
and the Japanese have done it as well
they have a name for it I don't want to
pronounce it because I don't wanna
butcher I don't even know how to say it
starts with the K okay Kazu I think okay
and it's basically it's kind of like how
do you know how Yamaha makes motorcycles
pianos and chainsaws and it's kind of
like that like they like are known for
doing that and so what are you okay so I
was saying what I respect the mob bank
did it too right so what I was saying
was what I respect the most is people
who who you know create their own
playbook and how they wouldn't live
their life and I agree what off what
what would be your cuz like I think you
kind of like they're like local types
you love researching what do you think
is like your highest highest bit thing
you respect people the same you said it
best I agree with what you said people
who people who look at the world and be
like yeah I get it the world's this way
I'm gonna bend the world to make it my
way though and have you like in your own
small way do you think have you done
that like what's an example of where
you've bent the world into working the
way you want it
I think that I'm from Missouri I think
that some of my friends from Missouri
think that I have done that I do not
think that I have done that right but I
think give it time and I will I think
some of the things you did with the
hustle were like that so for example you
didn't go to the VC route in fact you
did some weird [__] like crowdfunding
and other stuff along the way and from
the beginning I think you I remember you
distinctly saying cuz I was like why
don't you do Facebook you know why don't
you to video why don't you snapchat this
it's hot and you were like no I want to
do email because that's my own little
pirate ship that I can own and not
dependent on any other platform I want
to make my own part chip and I want to
get my part to be a big [__] pirate
ship and I just never really heard
anyone talk like that or think like that
where they were so specific around the
like the path to victory dude I have a
video like I'm normally I try not to
brag on myself because I think I got a
lot of flaws but the way our company is
shaping now I made a video in 2015 in my
outline what was gonna happen and it is
100% happening exactly like that where's
that video on youtube if you google the
hustle scene vests I explain I go we're
gonna build you a million people we're
gonna profit from advertising we're
gonna use all that profit to build more
stuff and we're gonna sell that stuff
and then we're gonna build more media
around it and it is happening exactly
and do you know how you said pirate ship
let me show you something hold on let me
show you so but stay there mr. Sam just
dropped his pants I'm looking at a giant
pirate ship tattoo on his thigh when did
you get that into da like right around
what I was telling you about the cousin
I got a pirate ship and it says bald
fast fine so you basically that's how
you tattooed your business plant under
your thigh yes
I tell everyone I go email this is our
pirate ship and every email is a little
bit of wind in our sails
I love it that's great okay we gotta end
on that that's a classic I should have
taken screen shot of that one okay so we
will see you guys to z' day we're gonna
have Andrew on when we say Tuesday
that's what we record these come out it
looks like a freaking loose cannon right
now with the Mohawk and tattoos and I
actually like that all right man
I will catch you later okay
[Music]
you